hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't get caught - now
you may be wondering yourself what
exactly are we not getting caught doing
well imagine actually don't imagine
anything because there's no scenario
that I can play out that it's Oh your
goal is to jack off before Fitz gets
close to you decided to do your [ __ ]
after work at work however there's a
problem you work with this is don't get
caught - I'm pretty sure I've played
don't get caught one it's some kind of
game similar to it if I haven't I'll go
back and play this one but this was a
horror game you don't have a car yet so
she's waiting for your ass to get the
[ __ ] out of that toilet and go with her
home sometimes out of annoyance she will
walk inside the restroom to check where
the heck you are you need to pretend
you're not there so she [ __ ] up we have
to do is turn off the lights using your
laptop you're a goddamn hacker after all
and then zip up your pants when your mom
checks the toilets all you need to focus
on screen as fast as possible to predict
getting caught use 8 interactive stuff
hold a and D to look around sometimes
you look good we'll check on you from
above so make sure to shine a flashlight
press C from time to time if you don't
do it fast enough you will get your
willy shoved up here I don't remember
what buttons I'm supposed to press I'm
about looking and Q and then jacking off
[Laughter]
okay
oh is this made by the same person that
made spaghetti because it seems awfully
similar okay here we try again
there we go oh yeah that's the good
stuff oh there we go that's what I'm
talking about oh yeah okay
oh now we're getting somewhere oh ha ha
oh yeah oh there we go okay hang on wait
hello dad
mom-mom you there mom are you there I
heard footsteps whatever I didn't see
dad dad I don't know what's happening oh
I forgot about the button I didn't know
mom
ah this is a perfectly normal game okay
everyone just go ahead and forgive me oh
I don't know what's happening here but
here we go
hello I guess it was nothing corn corn
corn wait wait wait wait I'm just not
good as if it up a fly I'm dog time our
talking there's no way to win this game
there's no way this game is unwinnable
all right listen guys I this is a low
point in that listen if you could if you
could just not judge me for playing
number one playing this game and number
two being bad at this game just you
cannot judge me and then we can all move
on as better people and by better people
I mean much worse people we are all much
worse people for me playing this game
and you watching this game so no one is
free of sin in this video no one not me
not you so if you commit to this now and
forgive me then we're all in this
together and we can all share the burden
of the sin and then we can move on from
the sin because there's a lot of sin but
if we share the load then we'll be okay
makes sense all right all right we can I
need your word on this one I need
absolutely your word this is we're in
this together now we're all in this
toilet fapping away we're all here
unfortunately unfortunately it's this
video's age-restricted it's d monetize
it's practically banned already if
you've made it this far I can't help you
but we can all help each other make
sense all right let's get a big circle
I like the corn dad why D - yo ha ha ha
finally now we're talking I'll come back
to you later ok dad ok ok
there we are
dad oh hi hello
h-hi mom just busy doing stop working
real hard that's all dad okay look I'm
not proud of this I don't think any of
us are my hand is cramping up but that's
okay mom dad mom dad look I know you're
not proud of me right now
but I could be doing worse things 50%
there we're almost 50% done with this oh
hi dad dad dad
oh god damn it this is impossible
there's my hands cramping up
which I guess is analogous for what I'm
doing but also I just feel achy died I
don't like it by this I don't like this
I don't like this I don't wanna do it I
must have been relatively close cuz I
can't see oh whatever
alright nevermind alright we're gonna
forget that it's all icky oh good I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do the other game
mode because I can't do the clicking
anymore I'm gonna try there's another
control scheme let's see if this will
work better
Oh Gary oh hey what oh that's better
[Applause]
now we coochie mom mom focused right on
mom this game is broken
alright [ __ ] that's [ __ ] where
my my pants was unzipped wasn't it my my
dick was out wasn't it
I think dick was extremely out wasn't it
[Applause]
mom it's broken it's broken its broken
its broken it's smoking the smoke and
the smoke is broken its broken and I my
pants were cept okay this is impossible
and frankly I don't want to beat it
because the the idea of beating it is
not a state of being that I want to be
in I don't want to be that guy I'd only
be that guy that's fat and at work and
we're all worse off for it anyway so I'm
gonna like I'm gonna get some goddamn
common sense in this [ __ ] and just end
it so we're done here so thank you
everybody so much for watching please go
wash your eyes out with bleach please go
scrub your hands until they're raw and
bleeding because you need to wash away
the
sinn there's nothing good here if you
made it to this part of the video you
are damned for all eternity
just get out while you can and we'll all
try to be better and forget about this
whole incident okay forget this video
happens No thank you for watching don't
see me in another video like this have a
good day bye bye
[Music]